TRANSITION I'M GONNA GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE WEDNESDAY
JANUARY THIRTIETH.
MEETING OF THE RULES COMMITTEE
TO ORDER MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU AGAIN CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS GROWTH.
GROWTH HERE MONNING.
HERE MONNING HERE ROTH.
WILK RESIDENTS WILL CURE ATKINS
HERE ATKINS HERE.
THANK YOU ARM SO WE HAVE ARE ON
THE AGENDA --
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE A MOTION AYE
IT THESE ARE PRETTY STANDARD
FLORA KNOWLEDGE MANSON.
NUMBER ONE THE BILL REFERRALS SO
IF SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH RIGHT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY.
SENATORS GROWTH GROVE AYE
MONNING.
MONNING AYE ROTH WILK AYE WILK
AYE ATKINS NINE ATKINS I FOUR
ZERO THAT --
PASSES FOUR ZERO WITH MISTER
ROTH A ABSENT.
HIGH I NOW WILL GO TO EXECUTIVE
SESSION.
AND THESE ARE THE RULES
COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS ARE